hey there I'm Tyson echo I'm Lani pits
or and this is Dragon Ball Z a bridge
behind the scenes episode two Dragon
Ball Z a bridge began as a humble fan
made project created by Scott Kaiser
neckl frerichs nick lani Peter Landis
and Curtis Takahata 101 are not which
quickly grew to become much greater than
the sum of its parts to say the least
and with the success of season 1 now in
the books the team would begin gearing
up for the Herculean task of tackling
the frieza saga earlier this year I've
reached out to Scott the director and
co-creator of Dragon Ball Z a bridge to
ask if he would like to share his
experiences and insights regarding his
time spent on this part of the show
thankfully he agreed and along with Nick
land as they diligently answered all of
my questions regarding what would become
their most ambitious and popular project
to date
our gun too
are you doing ah nothing the leap in
Dragonball Z of bridges popularity is
clear from seasons one to two when did
you think the show itself got better
episode what was that
14 13 rpms 14 it was around that point
where we suddenly had to expand the cast
like we went from characters that we had
been writing for a while and it was like
okay no we now have our main villain
we have his henchman we have denday and
marui nail yeah like everybody like the
cast exploded from season 1 and we
needed to pull in more people or at
least find more voices amongst ourselves
to do that yeah and it's also here where
we wanted to like lean back from some of
those also random jokes and actually try
to focus on character and like how those
characters relate to each other just
make actual character comedy part of
that stems from how we started writing
Frieza we have more of those things back
at the ship it's not like we're losing
anything valuable we didn't think to
write him like this but not even
unintentionally it just coincidentally
kind of hearkened back to something like
do be Griffin can't be evil like is evil
and loving it yes he is absolutely in
love with the violence that he inflicts
upon other people and furthermore is
absolutely in control of almost every
scene he is in until he isn't no that
was a rhetorical question and I gave you
a rhetorical answer good lord I traded
Vegeta for this and that was why in that
opening scene we just made sure that his
quips were incredibly dark Frieza
arguably were the most infamous villains
in anime history would play an integral
role in the episodes to come and saga at
large he needed to be measured sinister
ruthless but above all else
funny certainly a tough tightrope to
walk for any voice actor in the
recording booth and so finding the right
man for the job became a top priority
when it came to cast for season 2 I'd be
remiss not to mention little kuribohs
performances Frieza who reached out to
who and what was that like this is
really funny actually um we were testing
for Jinyu
we weren't sure who was going to play it
because originally Frieza was going to
be you yeah doing the doing a Linda
young impression I sounded like this
Jesse monkeys it sounds awful now I'm
glad I didn't do it but we were casting
for ginyu and I thought to myself huh it
would be really funny if little Creepo
ended up playing ginyu right yeah and he
sent us an audition like where like the
scene where Jinyu is talking to Frieza
about the Dragon Balls
but his Frieza was just so on point yeah
like I was just sitting there
no he even admitted it was a still
audition for Frieza it's a funny scene
that he wrote himself between Frieza and
give you and yeah he's giving you was
good his freezer was perfect you are
certainly on the ball today captain
ginyu if you are a dog I'd scratch your
belly if you were a cat I'd give you all
milk until you started to purr but since
you are neither of these things what if
I was a giraffe what pretend I'm a
giraffe so it's like well I guess we'll
find another voice for kidding you cuz
you're freezing
yeah you're freezing now and we end up
with aunt fish's getting you and he blew
it out of water too and in the session
that I think I remember most is either
those the first episode where he's in
his second form which was a lot of fun
where he gets to kind of you know move
down to his base and stuffing - locally
son that was a lot of fun uh I think
he'd bail that is my favorite way to
kill a person but the other thing that I
remember just because I knew how hard
this line was going to hit the moment
that he recorded it which was freezes
going to going to don't mind me
by all means give me some ideas it was
my favorite delivery of that entire
season it made my skin crawl the first
time I heard I'm like dude that was also
the point where oh cool he can also be
is menacing wouldn't we were writing
when we had to get to Goku vs. Frieza we
were so worried we we were very worried
about that because up until that point
Vegeta played off freezes so well Vegeta
is like pompous attitude
bouncing off of freezes flippant not
giving a [ __ ] about his pompous attitude
that's right you're not dealing with the
average Saiyan warrior anymore Frieza
it'll just put him in his place every
time as soon as Goku showed up on the
fields like oh man we don't have
pachitea here anymore to bounce off a
Frieza
once we started writing for that and
realizing that Goku is just too dumb to
understand for Freeze's threats yes that
that light bulb just went off for us
like oh no this is gonna be great
yeah they have they have a way better
dynamic than we ever even imagined how
do you function hey I'm just like any
other guy I pay my taxes one leg at a
time Frieza had become a welcomed
addition to the cast bouncing well off
of the overzealous and prints the
endlessly idiosyncratic ginyu force and
of course the lovably simple Goku
however and perhaps more importantly the
expanded cast featured in season 2
offered team four star countless
hilarious opportunities to manipulate
existing plot lines introduce new jokes
and establish fresh takes on classic
pre-existing and newly introduced
characters what were some of the moments
you were most excited to write for in
season 2
there was one joke I know we came up
with very early on which was when
Crillon is getting stabbed
we had our D and E she had the own
counters like okay he does it like a
bunch of times just bucking him up and
down we need a 1 up there like which
inadvertently we did not plan this but
people have pegged you
oh so that's why he survived the Spirit
Bomb and came back to earth that's how
he survived those two things he had 2
extra lives like we just accept that
like yeah yeah no we really plan ahead
for those things
hey thanks die
why'd through that entire saga just
trying to come up with like writing for
the ginn use the oh man writing for the
Ginn use was actually tougher than you
think because they're already these wild
crazy characters but we found some
niches for them we found some things to
lean on and go full force on I'm still
very proud of just having Rick oome
being a meathead pro wrestler instead of
words that I'm not allowed to say on the
internet for what they do in the dub
Riku macri's despite the show primarily
serving as a parody the creative freedom
team forced our head over the project
allowed them to make narrative and
character changes fans of the source
material would have appreciated armed
with decade's worth of hindsight the
team could write jokes and in some cases
entire characters knowing full well how
they were going to progress and how they
were going to participate in the story
moving forward how did you decide what
to change and what to put your own spin
on when it came to like diverging from
the source material entirely I think the
first real big one was turning guru into
a genocide ulm on stir nobody's gonna
see that coming I mean first we did it
for shock value by the way not planned
at first it wasn't until we came up with
the outline Mickey aligned when he what
he said oh and I'll buy no namekian
killer lack of arrest and then we're
like wait well what were the rest and
wait what happened there was a drought
and oh wait we have something that we
can work with here yeah the original
version was a storm that ravaged the
planet we turned it into a drought and
we made the drought because guru drank
all of the water got fat and then blamed
the drought on the albino namekians
leading to a genocide that would then
basically seal his death at the end of
season two we tried to hint at that
pretty hard with the Lord slug movie
saying that he was the evil half of Lord
slug deer slug and as I
your other half if you're looking for a
good time head up earth I hear they've
got dragon balls there it's hard to say
exactly why we did every single change
that we did some were significantly less
successful than others but you know I
mean personally I'm a huge huge fan of
the Comi piccolo conversation before the
fuse that was another one ride just sat
down and I wrote originally once piccolo
fused with his other half commie the
latter was written off the show entirely
effectively finding the only way to
truly end a character in the Dragon Ball
mythos however the clever addition of an
internalized monologue between kami and
piccolo not only allowed the team to
keep a beloved character relevant in
their own creative way but it also gave
piccolo someone to go back and forth
with at any time opening up countless
opportunities for character growth and
comedy his fusion with comi was of
course welcomed by the community however
it wasn't the first time team four star
pulled this clever trick it was so long
ago but once the idea was brought up it
was like yes that makes perfect sense
because as soon as like we get back to
anywhere piccolo is alone yeah and it
gave us something to do whenever piccolo
is fighting he had something to go back
and forth with hi two guys now so it
really did develop better than we could
have expected it made for so many
moments where piccolo could reflect on
something and think internally and have
a conversation all these scenes where
you know Piccolo's always that silent
guy who never says a lot we got to make
funnier and even give depth yeah and we
gave us like in case it didn't work we
gave ourselves the easy out of should
fade into your subconscious sooner or
later innovative ideas like the radition
of nail Comi and Piccolo's internalized
monologue was most certainly inventive
and celebrated however the true standout
moment of this arc was yet to come
despite containing some of the most
compelling and detestable villains best
character moments and one of the most
captivating cat-and-mouse games
utilizing all of the major and minor
players in the cast the frieza saga
would be remembered first and foremost
as the backdrop of what is still to this
day widely accepted as one of the most
iconic snapshots in animation history
[Music]
what
[Music]
how did you guys approach the famous
super saiyan scene we knew one thing
specifically the Crillon had to go out
on a joke
yep and that you can't immediately
proceed a joke with a serious moment
like that so we knew that Goku going
super saiyan had to be the start of the
next episode that was first and foremost
because you can't have that shift in
tone and then end if you're going to end
a parody of a comedy you have to like go
out on a joke or go out on an oh [ __ ]
moment
Goku going super saiyan felt like way
too big of a thing to end on it needed
to kind of be the the starts of episode
30 and onward when we actually
approached to that scene proper as how
to ride it we kind of just decided okay
the actual transformation itself can be
mostly serious reason can kind of be
making jokes on the background but
though Goku at this point he is not
upset that you know oh Crillon owed him
money or like or some stupid reason like
that he just lost his best friend I'm
going to break you what like a KitKat
bar he was in that moment where kuku
finally got to be the serious character
because he doesn't get a lot of those
moments any any and we needed to write
that mood shift for him from that
flippant oh hey you know I'm the
underdog in this fight we can we can try
to pull this off too I'm pissed and I'm
going to [ __ ] kill this guy you guys
get out of here get back to the ship but
what about you piccolo dies and all this
was pointless
take him get to the ship and get out of
here
despite Dragon Ball Z abridged being a
parody of Akira Toriyama's original work
the team felt it necessary to give the
Super Saiyan transformation scene the
respect it deserves
for the first time scripting their
incarnation of the character Goku as a
much more serious Saiyan warrior and
with that season 2 came to a close
achieving Heights far exceeding any
reasonable expectation for a simple fan
made parody a well and truly tough act
to follow
after the success of season 2 was there
any anxiety about approaching the rest
of the series oh god yeah there was a
lot of anxiety
during the production of the like near
the finale of season 2 because at this
point we had been doing it for what five
years at that point I think episode 30
was our fifth anniversary even at that
point we were starting to feel the burn
making these episodes month to month
sometimes a little longer in between
sometimes a little shorter it was a
point where we had to ask ourselves you
know at what point do we want to end
this and there was a conversation about
ending at the episode 30 finale at a
certain point we were going back for us
like we can do like these other things
like but we still have this when you
still do this and it's like it was also
at this point where our channel had been
taken down for the first time oh yeah
yeah because that was a big stroke for
us like look if we don't have a channel
we don't have things to put out and it's
like cuz YouTube was shifting way more
to the side of corporations the pendulum
swung back a bit now it's going the
other way it's it's it's been a weird
process in that front so there was a
point in time where we actually thought
about ending it at season two yeah
ultimately we decided to continue on to
the androids and sell at that point that
was probably where the most of the
pressure came from near the end of Nanak
for us and that was all internal stuff
that we never talked about outwardly
that was a little bit stressful for us
because after yeah after five years of
working on the same project you have to
stand back and say okay this is another
five years of our life to do this
because even just for season 3 which had
more episodes still because as
Dragonball went on each arc had
progressively more episodes to it yeah
and that was that was pretty stressful
and a little bit scary at that time but
I'm really really obviously glad that we
went through with it because season 3 is
my favorite season it's just my favorite
season 2 went above and beyond in both
the writing and production departments
far exceeding any and all expectations
left behind after season 1 delivering
magnificent moments delightful humor and
titillating voice acting their sophomore
outing into the Dragon Ball narrative
was most definitely their strongest to
date having now started to produce a
product with a level of polish rivaling
official productions the team took a
well-deserved 6-month break before
returning to what will become their most
ambitious project to date I am Perth
and you will quote everything I say if
you would like to see our coverage of
season 1 you can check out that on team
force 2 has official YouTube channel
right here and if you're interested in
seeing the final part of this
documentary series covering Dragon Ball
Z abridges third season the cell saga
and all that went into its creation
subscribe to be the first person to see
it next week thanks for watching